Hace 15 años, fui a visitar a un amigo en Hong Kong.
En esa época yo era muy supersticioso.
Así que, al aterrizar -- todavía en el antiguo aeropuerto de Hong Kong
llamado Kai Tak, cuando estaba justo en medio de la ciudad --
-- pensé: Si veo algo bueno, me lo voy a pasar muy bien aquí
estas dos semanas. Y si veo algo negativo, va ser un desastre.
Así que el avión aterrizó entre los edificios
y se detiene frente a este pequeño cartel.
(Risas)
Y de hecho fui a ver algunas de las compañias de diseño
en Hong Kong durante mi estancia
y resultó que --
sólo fui para ver, ya saben, que están haciendo en Hong Kong.
Pero de hecho me fui con una gran oferte de trabajo.
Y volví a Austria, hice mis maletas.
Y, una semana más tarde, estaba de vuelta en Hong Kong
todavía supersticioso y pensando: Bueno, si todavía está esa cartelera de "Winner" (ganador)
Lo voy a pasar muy bien trabajando aquí.
(Risas)
Pero si no está, va a ser estresante y un desastre.
Así que resultó que no solo el cartel todavía seguía ahí
sino que habían puesto éste al lado.
(Risas)
Por otro lado, ésto me enseñó a dónde me lleva la superstición
porque realmente lo pasé fatal en Hong Kong.
(Risas)
De todos modos, tuve varios momentos de verdadera felicidad en mi vida --
-- de, ya saben, creo que el folleto de la conferencia se refiere a
momentos que te quitan la respiración.
Y como soy muy bueno haciendo listas, los puse a todos en una.
(Risas)
Ahora, no es necesario que se tomen la molestia de leerlo
y yo no lo voy a leer para ustedes.
Ya sé lo verdaderamente aburrido que es escuchar sobre la felicidad de otras personas.
(Risas)
Lo que hice, sin embargo, es mirarlos desde el punto de vista del diseño
y eliminé aquellos que no tenían nada que ver con el diseño.
Y, para mi sorpresa, alrededor de la mitad de ellos, tenían relación con el diseño.
Así que hay, por supuesto, dos opciones.
Hay uno desde el punto de vista del consumidor --
-- en el que soy feliz mientras experimento el diseño.
Y les daré un ejemplo. Había recibido mi primer Walkman.
En 1983.
Mi hermano tenía su gran moto Yamaha
que estaba dispuesto a prestarme libremente.
Y el casete de "Synchronicity" de Police
que justo acababa de salir
y no había ninguna ley para usar casco en mi pueblo natal de Bregenz.
Así que podía conducir por las montañas
disfrutando libremente a The Police en el nuevo Sony Walkman.
(Risas)
Y lo recuerdo como un momento de felicidad.
Por supuesto que éstos están relacionados en una combinación
de al menos dos objetos de diseño.
Y, ya saben, existe una escala de felicidad cuando hablamos de diseño
pero el incidente con la moto estaría, ya saben
situado en algun lugar aquí -- entre Placer y Dicha.
Ahora, hay otra parte, desde el punto de vista del diseñador --
-- si eres feliz cuando lo estas haciéndolo.
Y una manera de ver cómo de feliz están los diseñadores cuando diseñan podría ser,
¿mirar a las fotos en la parte de atrás de sus monografías?
(Risas)
Así que, según esto, los australianos y los japoneses
al igual que los mejicanos
son muy felices.
(Risas)
Mientras que, de algún modo, los españoles
... y, en mi opinión, especialmente los suizos
(Risas)
no la están pasando tan bien.
El pasado Noviembre se inaguró un museo en Tokyo, llamado Museo Mori
en un rascacielos, arriba en el piso 56.
Y su exposición inagural se llamaba "Felicidad".
Y fui muy emocionado a verla porque --
Bueno, estaba ya pensando en esta conferencia.
Y muy curiosamente la exhibición estaba separada en cuatro áreas.
Bajo "Arcadia" mostraban cosas como ésta, del periodo Edo --
-- cien maneras distintas de escribir "felicidad".
O tenían esta manzana de Yoko Ono -- que, por supuesto, más tarde
se convertiría en el sello para The Beatles.
Bajo "Nirvana" mostraban este cuadro de Constable.
Y aquí había una pequeña -- una interesante teoría acerca de la abstracción.
Éste es un campo azul -- de hecho es un cuadro de Yves Kline.
Y la teoría era, que si se abstrae una imagen, realmente, saben,
se puede abrir un gran espacio para lo irrepresentable --
-- y que por lo tanto, permite al espectador involucrarse más.
Luego, bajo "Deseo", mostraban estas pinturas Shunsho
-- también del período Edo -- tinta sobre seda.
Y por último, bajo "Harmonía", tenían esta mandala del Tibet del siglo 13.
Ahora, lo que me hizo salir de la exhibición fue,
quizás con la exepción de la mandala,
la mayoría de las piezas ahí eran sobre de la visualización de la felicidad,
no sobre la felicidad.
Y me sentí un poco engañado, porque la visualización
--es lo realmente fácil de hacer.
Y, ya saben, mi estudio -- lo hemos hecho todo el tiempo.
Ésto es, ya saben, un libro.
Un perro feliz -- y lo haces salir, es un perro agresivo.
Ésto es un David Bryne feliz y un David Bryne enojado.
O un poster de jazz con un rostro feliz y un rosto mas agresivo.
Saben, no es un gran logro.
Y se ha llevado al punto donde, uds. saben, en publicidad
o en la industria del cine, "feliz" se ha ganado tan mala reputación
que si realmente se quiere hacer algo con el tema
y aún parecer auténtico, casi hay que, ya saben
hacerlo desde un punto de vista cínico.
Ésto es, ya saben, el poster de una película.
O mi estudio, que diseñamos hace un par de semanas una caja conjunto de "The Talking Heads"
donde la felicidad que se visualizaba en la cubierta era definitivamente mucho mas oscura.
Mucho, bastante más difícil es éste, donde el diseño de hecho puede evocar felicidad.
Les mostraré tres que, de hecho, lograron este efecto conmigo.
Ésta es una campaña hecha por un artista joven en Nueva York, que se llama a sí mismo "True" (Verdad).
Todo aquel que haya usado el metro de Nueva York estará
familiarizado con estas señales.
El artista pintó su propia versión de estas señales
Se reunió cada miércoles en una parada del metro con 20 de sus amigos.
Dividieron las diferentes líneas del metro y añadiendo su propia versión
(risas)
Ésta es una.
Pues, ésto funciona porque nadie nunca mira estas señales.
Así que
(risas)
si se está aburrido en el metro, y se mira a algún lugar,
y tarda un instante hasta que de hecho --
se entiende que dice algo distinto a lo que normalmente diría.
(risas)
Quiero decir, al menos, cómo me hizo feliz.
Ahora, este artista "True" es un humanitario de verdad.
No quiso que arrestasen a ninguno de sus amigos,
así que les dio a todos esta tarjeta falsa de voluntario.
(risas)
Y también les dio esta carta falsa del AMT --
como pretendiendo que es un proyecto artístico
financiado por la Autoridad Metropolitana del Tránsito.
(risas)
Otro proyecto de Nueva York.
Ésto es en P.S. 1 -- una escultura que es básicament un cuarto cuadrado
de James Turrell, que tiene un techo retraible.
Se abre al atardecer y al amanecer todos los dias
No se vé el horizonte,
simplemente se está ahi, viendo los increibles, sutiles cambios en el color del cielo.
El cuarto realmente merece la pena ser visto.
La gente cambia cuando entra ahí
y, tengan claro, no he vuelto a mirar al cielo de la misma manera
después de pasar una hora ahí.
Existen, por supuesto, mas que esos tres proyectos que les he mostrado.
Podría decir definitivamente que observando la "Nube" de Vik Muniz
hace un par de años en Manhattan, me hizo feliz también.
Pero mi último proyecto es, de nuevo, de un joven diseñador de Nueva York.
Es de origen Koreano.
Y se tomó la tarea de imprimir 55.000 burbujas de diálogo
-- pegatinas de burbujas de diálogo vacías, grandes y pequeñas.
Y va por Nueva York y simplemente las coloca, vacías, en los pósters.
(risas)
Y otras personas las llenan.
Ésta dice: Por favor déjenme morir en paz
(risas)
Creo que fue --
lo más sorprendente para mi fue que lo escrito de hecho estaba muy bien
Ésta está en un poster de un músico, que dice:
Estoy preocupado de que mi CD no venda más de 200.000 unidades
y que, como consecuencia, el adelanto de la disquera
me será arrebatado
Después de ello, mi contrato será cancelado
y estaré de nuevo haciendo covers de Journey en la Calle Bleecker
(risas)
Creo que la razón por la cual ésto funciona tan bien es que todo el que se involucre gana
Jee logra hacer su proyecto;
el público obtiene un ambiente más agradable;
y distinto público obtiene un espacio donde expresarse;
y los publicistas finalmente logran que alguien mire sus anuncios
(risas)
Bueno, había una pregunta, que por supuesto se me quedó en la mente un tiempo:
uds. saben, ¿puedo hacer más cosas de las que me gusta hacer de diseño
y menos cosas de las que no me gusta hacer?
Lo que me hizo regresar a mis listas
-- uds. saben, sólo para ver qué es lo que realmente me gusta de mi trabajo
Una es: simplemente trabajar sin presión
Luego: trabajar concentrado, sin estar exhausto
O, como dijo Nancy antes, realmente sumergirse en ello
Tratar de no atorarse haciendo la misma cosa --
-- o tratar de no atorarse en la computadora todo el dia
Ésto está, claro, relacionado: salir del estudio
Luego, desde luego, tratar de, ya saben, trabajar en cosas
donde el contenido sea realmente importante para mi
Y ser capaz de disfrutar de los resultados
Y entonces encuentro otra lista en uno de mis diarios que contenía
todas las cosas que pensé que había aprendido hasta ahora en mi vida
Y, casi justo en ese momento, una revista austríaca llamó a preguntar
si quería hacer seis páginas -- diseñar seis páginas
que funcionen como páginas divisorias entre los diferentes capítulos de la revista
Y todo el asunto cayó en su lugar
Así que simplemente tomé una de las cosas que pensé haber aprendido
-- en este caso, "Todo lo que hago siempre regresa a mi"
-- e hicimos estas páginas con referencia a esto
Así que fue: TODO
LO QUE HAGO
SIEMPRE
SE
VUELVE
A MI.
Hace una par de semanas, una
(risas)
compañía francesa nos pidió diseñar cinco carteleras para ellos
De nuevo, pudimos proveer el contenido
Así que tomamos otra
Y esto fue hace dos semanas
Volamos a Arizona -- el diseñador que trabaja conmigo y yo --
-- y fotografiamos ésta.
Así que es : TRATAR
DE VERME
BIEN
LIMITA
MI VIDA.
Y luego hicimos una más de éstas
De nuevo para una revista, páginas separadoras
Esta es : TENER
esto, es lo mismo
-- solo, bueno, lo fotografiamos desde el costado
Ésta desde el frente
y es: AGALLAS
De nuevo, es la misma cosa -- "AGALLAS", solo que vuelto a hacer en el mismo lugar
y luego: SIEMPRE
FUNCIONA
y luego "PARA" con la luz encendida
(risas)
y este soy "MI".
Muchas gracias
(Aplauso)